oui
à l'âge de 12 ans valentine sagnol a été
renversée par un camion
les médecins ont dû amputer sa jambe
droite
il a une prothèse qui porte uniquement
pour aller à l'église depuis 45 ans cet
agriculteur travail cetera hangar situé
sur la côte est de l'île avec les des
béquilles je plante sur deux hectares
amateur commence ici et montent jusqu'au
sommet du ce matin il désherber le tour
de mes banane john g 750 pieds de
bananes jaune ici et 350 pieds ailleurs
valant times en eut elle a commencé dont
la banane
le secteur s'est effondrée fin des
années 90 quand les producteurs car et
payants ont perdu l'accès privilégié au
marché européen
les multi nationaux américains
propriétaires de vastes bananeraies en
amérique latine avait gagné un procès
contre l'union européenne pour
concurrence déloyale des milliers de
plantes aka réveillant ont été ruinés
dans l'entente et sagnol a tous utilisés
l'herbicide glyphosate pour nettoyer ses
champs il regrette l'interdiction
introduit en août 2010 8 de ce produit
[Musique]
si je pouvais utiliser le glyphosate
pour contrôler les mauvaises herbes
en l'espace de quatre jours j'aurais pu
nettoyer la totalité de mes deux
hectares
maintenant ils embauchent trois
personnes pour nettoyer ses champs il
plante dépassait contre ces bananes
jaune c'est pour empêcher les mauvaises
herbes de repousser et augmenter ses
revenus au pouvoir payer son personnel
sur notre pain salle se trouve ce lieu
de stockage
ils ne contiennent que de l'engrais les
consignes de sécurité sont les seuls
témoins à une époque où les plantes et
utiliser toutes sortes de produits
chimiques dont les chants valentin une
championne ne reçoit aucune aide
chaque mois il doit dépenser 300 euros
pour l'achat de produits phytosanitaires
et pour l'engrais saipan des réseaux
informels appelée localement les trafics
heures que valentine sagnol exporte ses
bananes john teller barbade
les prix ne sont pas fixes ils essayent
de maintenir un tarif de 13 euros pour
un carton de 22 kg certains trafics
heures près de les marchandises sans
nous pays
par exemple je peux récolté l'équivalent
de 260 euros de produits j'ai déjà fait
des projets pour cet argent mais quand
je suis enfin payer parfois je ne reçois
que des deux tiers même la moitié après
avoir déduit ces freins il empoche 22
euros par jour il s'autorise des congés
d'une semaine tous les deux ans âgé de
60 ans dans le times en eut elle
voudrait bien prendre sa retraite
la mauvaise performance
c'est ici aussi
habillés en bleu ici à gauche et
présidente de l'association des femmes
dans l'agriculture
fondée en 2010 le groupe compte 26
membres
rogers qui motive ces terres à son souci
sur la côte atlantique
elle a 60 ans ça fait longtemps qu'elle
a abandonné la culture de la banane et
l'utilisation de produits chimiques
aujourd'hui des membres de son groupe
sont venus lui donner un coup de main
dans ses champs de tomates de chou et
d'autres produits maraîchers
ces cultivateurs expérimentés savent ce
qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui on arrache les mauvaises
herbes
on plante des jeunes pousses et on
s'occupe des tomates ordre et écoule sa
production dans des supermarchés locaux
pour éloigner les parasites
elle plante de l'oignon pays à proximité
de ces choux les piments forts et la
montre sont aussi efficaces contre les
bestioles
des pans n'utilise aucun produit
chimique sur les légumes c'est parce que
nous l'aimons sont aussi on essaie
d'éviter des pesticides
c'est pour cela que je t'en ai mes
tomates quand ils ont moins de
feuillages les insectes ne vient pas
assez nasa j'utilise ma recette d'un
liquide vaisselle et piment je mélange
et je l'appliqué sur les plantes
spécialiste de la protection des
récoltes travail pour candy l'institut
caribbean pour la recherche agricole
présent dans tous les pays de la
communauté caribéenne la caricom sa
mission donner des conseils gratuits aux
agriculteurs de saint vincent
son budget ne lui permet pas de fournir
du matériel
je l'utilisé enfin quand je plantais la
banale mais vous n'avez pas applications
donc depuis l'interdiction vous n'avez
pas le problème non je n'utilise pas ces
produits c'est bien on y dispense à
saint-vincent-et-les-grenadines est le
seul pays membres de la caricom à avoir
interdit le glyphosate green lantern
prépare un rapport pour le gouvernement
sur l'avenir du monde agricole sont les
glyphosate
pour lui l'interdiction totale n'est pas
une solution fiable le glyphosate est un
herbicide très efficace grâce à sa
manière d'agir
il n'y a presque rien qui fonctionne
aussi bien trouver une alternative
hélas difficile le glyphosate réduit les
coûts de production parce qu'il réduit
les besoins en main d'oeuvre pour
désherber dans un autre champ le groupe
est d'un planteur avec sarah cote de
patates douces
c'est grâce à l'entr'aide que cette
association fonctionne
mais rick jackson à vendre ses légumes
pays aux îles vierges
on ne trouve pas des personnes qui
veulent travailler et le pire c'est le
vote les gens volent nos productions
c'est le plus grand problème dans
l'agriculture aujourd'hui en plus les
banques ne veulent pas nous prêter de
l'argent pour les projets agricoles
maintenant on fait tout manuellement si
on pouvait trouver de l'aide pour
acheter des machines pour travailler la
terre
ce serait une bonne chose pour nous
compte des événements l'oil & l'unique
hommes dont l'association
âgé de 63 ans c'est lui qui fait les
gros travaux pour les femmes des vignes
des banques creuser des trous pour
planter de l'igname blanche
je fais ça pour les femmes je prépare
les champs pour elle sans l'aide d'un
tracteur elles viennent m'aider sur mon
exploitation chez intégrer ce groupe en
je trouve qu'elles sont très sérieuses
de tous les groupes avec lesquels j'ai
essayé de collaborer c'est celui qui
fonctionne le mieux
dans la capitale kingston se trouve
l'ancien siège de l'association des
plantes de bananes dissous en 2009 après
l'effondrement de l'industrie bananière
c'est dans ce bâtiment que sont stockés
l'engrais et les pesticides vendus aux
agriculteurs ces sacs d'engrais de 50 kg
sont vendus 1 23 euro
en l'absence de subventions l'engrais et
vendus à prix coûtant
le nantais hogan's et le directeur
adjoint du département d'agriculture à
54 ans cet agronome de métier et la
présidente du comité de produits
phytosanitaires qui réglemente
l'importation des engrais et des
pesticides
chaque pesticide doit être évaluée pour
sa toxicité
son impact sur l'environnement comment
on pense que les planteurs vont s'en
servir
quelqu'un peut acheter un pesticide qui
n'est pas si dangereux que ça mais
qu'ils utilisent mal il faut tout
prendre en compte obtenir toutes les
informations
ensuite on prend la décision si on veut
autoriser un produit ou pas depuis
l'interdiction d'importer et de vendre
le glyphosate venant togo est inondé des
appels des planteurs qui veulent obtenir
les produits chimiques sont stockés dans
une autre réserve du bâtiment situé
derrière la caisse dont ses cartons se
trouvent les herbicides fongicides
pesticides insecticides et raticide qui
sont autorisés par vente par le comité
des produits phytosanitaires
certains d'entre eux sont encore plus
toxique que le glyphosate
c'était herbicides a été interdit par
l'union européenne en 2019
celui-ci utilisé dans la banane a été
retiré du marché français en 2010 est à
cause des risques pour la santé humaine
la paraquat un herbicide proposé aux
agriculteurs à la place du glyphosate
est interdit par l'union européenne
depuis 2007
il provoque à rennes un parkinson on
éloigne d'une vision d'une agriculture
saine à l'heure actuelle on importe plus
de l'ifo êtes les planteurs peuvent par
exemple utiliser le basta vous savez le
basta c'est un herbicide qui tue l'herbe
grasse et toutes sortes de mauvaises
herbes
actuellement c'est l'un des meilleurs
produits chimiques on a en magasin
le gouvernement veut redémarrer la
culture du tall man abandonnée dans les
années 60 en faveur de la banane cette
récolte n'a pas besoin d'un apport
important de produits phytosanitaires le
rhizome pouces dont les riches terres
volcaniques du north atlantic de
saint-vincent cultivés ici depuis
l'époque des amérindiens qui l'appelait
ma d'ango l'unique récolte de l'année
commence fin janvier déterrer les
rhizomes est un travail manuel
il faut avoir les reins solides chris
penn dania les agriculteurs et membre de
l'association des producteurs de tôle au
mans y cultive sur deux hectares et
pharma research et si un agriculteur et
bien formés il peut utiliser uniquement
les feuilles mortes et les étaler sur
les champs avec cette technique
on a besoin de tout d'engrais quand les
feuilles pourrissent
ça nourrit les reason selon votre
superficie vous pouvez gagner entre 5000
et 7000 euros par an selon la quantité
que vous transportez à l' usine en tant
qu'agriculteur je me dis que si je peux
gagner même 330 euros par mois
c'est-à-dire 4000 euros par an c'est bon
pour moi l'unique usine de
transformation se situant à l'extrême
nord de l'île dont la commune dow il ya
où se trouve la majorité des planteurs
de tout le monde saint vincent
construite en 1975 c'est la dernière des
dix usines à fonctionner sur l'île le
tourment et livrés et peser les plantes
sont rémunérés 66 centimes le kilo à la
livraison
on doit peser manuellement paf que la
balance mécanique sous laquelle les
camions passent est en panne
tout doit être transformée dans un délai
de deux semaines
sinon les rhizomes commence à pourrir
notre le mans brut et lavez les racines
sont arrachés 120 personnes sont
embauchées pour nom la période de la
récolte un emploi qui dure six mois
ces salariés viennent des communes de
saint denis b au bouillant et pointe qui
sont parmi les plus reculés de lille
lusine si elle ne tombe pas en panne
transformant des ronds aux mille kilos
de ryzom à pajot le processus nécessite
plusieurs étapes une fat uv risée
letourneau mère l'avait on les laisse
reposer dans ses cuves de béton pendant
24 heures rapporté des revenus réguliers
des revenus hebdomadaires
c'est tout le monde rapporte des revenus
annuels les planteurs ont choisi la
banane avec le déclin de la banane c'est
le taux le mans semble être de retour
c'est sur ces plateaux de séchage que
les derniers à traces de l'humidité
s'évapore de l'amidon de tôle au mans
qu'il xala ville âgé de 35 ans est
responsable de production
elle travaille ici depuis cinq ans elle
gagne 130 euros par quinzaine c'est un
point dure six mois
le reste du temps elle cultive des
produits maraîchers on peut le manger
comme ça
c'est bon à manger c'est aussi bon pour
préparer la bouillie pour les bébés et
les personnes âgées
le tout le monde et saint vincent et les
grenadines est emballé et vendus dans
les grandes surfaces à cause du déclin
de l'industrie lille a perdu ses marchés
internationaux les états unis par
exemple préfèrent acheter ce produit
moins cher en thaïlande
chaque samedi le marché de poissons de
kingston est rempli de clients
c'est le meilleur jour de la semaine
pour les marrante achats le 1er décembre
le gouvernement de saint vincent et les
grenadines a interdit la pêche du
poisson perroquet la surpêche de
l'espèce menace la ressource
ici on trouve toutes sortes de poissons
souffre le perroquet l'interdiction
semble être respectée winstead paris âgé
de 50 ans est président de
l'organisation des marins pêcheurs de
saint vincent et les grenadines
il s'occupe des intérêts des
professionnels sur la grande île de sein
récent les marins pêcheurs ne prenait
pas autant de poissons perroquets donc
on ne vend pas beaucoup de ces poissons
dits sur le marché de kingston
il faut partir dans les grenadines pour
rencontrer les mécontents
descoings l'île la plus au nord de
l'archipel et à une heure de trajet par
les ferries qui effectué plusieurs
rotations quotidiennes entre forme sur
la côte sud de bec way est une
communauté qui vit de la pêche depuis
deux siècles
une centaine de bateaux sont basés sur
ce pas ce qui représente le gagne pain
des 400 personnes et leurs familles le
métier de marin d'achat se transmet de
père en fils ils sont en colère ils
n'ont jamais été consultés par les
autorités sur l'interdiction établi en
décembre 2019 détaché le poisson car ok
ça fait 25 ans que je suis marré
pêcheurs je fais de la plongée sous
marine
c'est grâce à la pêche du poisson
perroquet que j'ai pu construire ma
maison je rajoute le perroquet aux
autres poissons que je pêche parce qu'il
n'ya pas assez espèces on ne peut pas
survivre sans le poisson pur obtient la
plus importante variété de poisson
aujourd'hui c'est le poisson perroquet à
l'étranger les gens aiment acheter ce
poisson c'est le poisson le plus
abondant ici on ne peut pas en épuiser
les stocks
on ne nous a jamais consulté on a tout
simplement entendu l'interdiction à la
radio il faut lever cette interdiction
il faut nous autorisés à pêcher ce
poisson pour qu'on puisse vivre on a
beaucoup d'enfants comment va-t-on faire
pour les envoyer à l'école pour acheter
les manuels scolaires pour payer nos
factures d'électricité les exportateurs
de langoustes et de poissons frais sont
également infectés par l'interdiction
depuis 30 ans 1 re à guy ancien douanier
gagne sa vie avec l'exploitation de
produits de la mer vers sainte lucie le
poisson perroquet représente 30% de son
chiffre d'affaires depuis l'interdiction
son bateau n'est pas parti il a besoin
de 1000 kg de poisson pour rentabiliser
le voyage ça fait une semaine que
j'attends j'ai sûrement 500 kg de
poissons si je pouvais acheter le
poisson perroquet j'aurai atteint mon
quota demain ou après demain pour
envoyer le bateau à sainte lucie à
porter le débat sur la côte ouest des
coûts et les propriétaires des centres
de plongée sont ravis ils estiment que
le poisson perroquet doit être protégé
chaque année depuis 1984 cette
entreprise à thiers 3000 plongeurs sous
marins sur les récifs de l'île quinté
saxe propriétaire du centre a constaté
un déclin de la population du point son
père au quai st on ne voit que rarement
le poisson perroquet un conte ciel en
bon de groupes d'adultes le poisson
perroquet rennes on le voit qu'au stade
juvénile
on ne voit pas quatre personnes dont
trois instructeurs tous habitants de bec
way travaille pour le centre de plongée
c'est eux qui emmène les plongeuses sur
les sites
la bonne santé des récifs et de la vie
sous-marine est primordial pour leur
avenir
beaucoup de personnes parlent du poisson
perroquet ici c'est l'une de nos
principales attractions différentes
couleurs il ya plusieurs variétés
il faut les protéger ils seront plus
faciles à attraper que les autres
poissons donc les pêcheurs les prennent
parce qu'ils ne fuient pas devant les
dix marins je plonge depuis trois ans et
quand j'ai débuté je voyais beaucoup
plus de poissons perroquets à cet
endroit
si tu plonges maintenant tu vas aller
voir mais pas dans les mêmes quantités
que je voyais quand j'ai commencé à
manger le poisson perroquet qu'on
appelle aussi le cartel jardiniers des
récifs coralliens sur ces vidéos
amateurs on le voit avec son bec forme
et 2000 dont soudés en train de manger
les coraux malades et les ags qui
asphyxie les récifs
on entend croquer la pierre même sous la
mer chaque poisson produit plus de 300
kilos de sable par an dans ses
excréments
selon les scientifiques les récifs
coralliens de la caraïbe sont menacées
par la surpêche du poisson perroquet
dont la population est au bord de
l'effondrement
ces images tournées par les départements
de la tâche de saint vincent et les
grenadines montre le déclin et la mort
de certains massifs
on y voit très peu de poissons
perroquets seulement quelques jours et
ni la saint vincent et les grenadines a
suivi le mexique bonheur et les bermudes
en interdisant la pêche de ce poisson au
département de la pêche les
fonctionnaires d'état et cds satisfaire
les demandes de tous ceux qui vivent des
ressources marines
le compromis entre la protection du
poisson perroquet et les des mondes
démarrante thatcher n'a pas encore été
trouvé
what we've seen est ce que nous avons
constaté avec beaucoup d'étonnement
c'est une augmentation de la population
de poissons perroquets il mais nous
n'avons pas vu une augmentation de la
taille des spécimens nous pensons qu'en
certains endroits il ya eu des périodes
de reproduction qui ont permis aux
poissons perroquets de se reproduire
mais pour que ça continue il faut que
ces poissons puissent atteindre l'âge de
leur condition donc nous allons
poursuivre nos études et nos évaluations
pour décider s'il faut maintenir une
interdiction totale ou si on met en
place des périodes fermé qui coïncide
avec la saison de saboter 6 ministre de
l'agriculture et de la pêche juriste de
formation c'est lui qui a pris la
décision d'interdire le glyphosate et
stopper la pêche du poisson perroquet il
est persuadé qu'il a le soutien de tous
les acteurs depuis plusieurs années à un
pourcentage important à nos agriculteurs
ont été exposés au produit chimique
dangereux avec la banane
cette utilisation de pesticides et
d'herbicides art voulons c'est donc
quand on a annoncé l'interdiction et on
a démarré les consultations nos
agriculteurs se sont souvenus de
l'époque où ils n'utilisaient pas encore
tous ses pôles - le rôle du poisson
perroquet dans le nettoyage des récifs
est d'une grande importance
les marins pêcheurs ont compris comme
sommes entrés de protéger l'eau gagne
pain mais il faut le faire dans un
objectif de conservation parce que si on
ne le fait pas l'art chose à disparaître
à deux heures de route de la capitale
kingston au nord de saint vincent
sous l'ombre du volcan la soufrière se
trouve le village de château bel air
c'est ici que la nec slam khan âgé de 63
ans cultive une exploitation
expérimentale sur des hectares
ancien président de la chambre de
commerce de saint vincent
il a vécu longtemps aux pays bas où il
travaillait dans l'informatique avec son
frère samuel âgé de 75 ans qui lui a
travaillé dans les chantiers navals de
dunkerque
il développe son aide du gouvernement
des méthodes alternatives d'une culture
saine et adaptée au climat de la caraïbe
du coup pour la tête des hommes pour que
cette phase il a grimpé de récolter je
veux c'est comme une échelle naturel on
a toujours perdu pourcentage important
de nos fruits et légumes donc on essaye
de rectifier ce problème
ça fait neuf ans qu'alain axe l'âme
qu'elle ne plante que des essences du
pays
corossol surette goyave et mangue parmi
d'autres les quarante variétés de fruits
sont cultivés sans produits
phytosanitaires pour irriguer ses shows
l'index l'âme qui ne recueille l'eau de
puits qui s'évacue dans les
canalisations
cette eau est stocké dans ses réservoirs
au ban de la route hors de ses bases la
route a une capacité d'environ 1,9
deux millions de litres d'eaux de
ruissellement parents sont la
pluviométrie de cette session les
absoluta est rarement coupé ce
cultivateur va minimiser les effets de
l'érosion garder l'humidité dont le sol
et nourrir les abeilles durant la saison
des pluies
je crois plus court mais maintenant
c'est comme ça l'herbe protège le sol
des ondes ultra violet et ça aide à
maintenir les microbes bénéfique qui
sont dans la terre à saint vincent et
les grenadines les initiatives
écologiques prises par le gouvernement
partait de bonnes intentions mais en
l'absence d'un plan de développement
structuré et cohérent pour l'agriculture
et la tâche en consultation avec tous
les acteurs
ces mesures insuffisantes et
fragmentaire ne vont pas fonctionné
[Musique]